il prospère en Europe grâce à la
prostitution le trafic d'êtres humains
et le trafic de drogue voici l'histoire
des cultes les gangs nigérian aux
croyances
occultes des agressions à la machette
c'est un phénomène encore hyper inconnu
ne me parlez pas juste d'une guerre
entre faction
nous sommes au mois de mai 2022 à
Marseille dans cette cité des quartiers
nord une rixe à la machette éclate entre
membres de la communauté nigériane
beaucoup de machettes qu'ils ont mis en
fait envie en fait dans la peur dans le
traumatisme on est dans une violence
extrême à l'origine de ces incidents des
gangs d'origine Nigéria leur lieu de vie
ce bâtiment dans lequel ils occupent les
appartements vides ou dont ils chassent
les habitants qui prospère dans la cité
phocène sont rattachés à des
organisations criminelles
internationales appelées les cultes ce
sont des organisations donc criminels
qui sont présentes quasiment sur les
cinq continents et qui sont actifs
notamment dans la traite d'êtres humains
dans le trafic de drogue et dans la
cybercriminalité moi j'habitais au
Nigeria et Johann tilluine mon confrère
avec qui on a fait cette enquête était
basée en France lui il couvrait des gros
procès liés justement des proxénètes
nigérian un apportant un réseau de
prostitution des monteliers à Marseille
14 personnes d'origine Nigéria ont été
interpellé mardi dernier il y a un
moment où on s'est dit il faut qu'on
essaye de faire la connexion et de
comprendre ce qui se passe plaignante
comme prévenu ils sont tous nigérian et
viennent de la même région du sud du
pays Vikings Black Cats ou encore
boucanier ses organisations criminelles
appelées cultes sont à l'origine des
confrères des étudiantes non violentes
nées dans les années 50 au sud du
Nigéria
le premier culte appelé pirate a été
fondé par un groupe d'étudiants
surnommés les 7 magnifiques leur
objectif lutter pour les droits de
l'homme et la justice sociale au Nigeria
parmi eux l'écrivain Wallet showinka qui
deviendra par la suite le premier prix
Nobel de littérature d'origine africaine
ce monsieur qui deviendra une sommité de
la littérature mondiale par la suite a
créé bien malgré lui un espèce de
Frankenstein on l'a rencontré et il est
le premier à son désolé aujourd'hui et à
justement vouloir qu'on parle de ce
phénomène de la manière dont ça s'est
dévoyé et dont ça a dégénéré
il porte malgré lui un petit peu le
péché originel
[Musique]
quelques années après la fondation des
pirates une scission donne naissance à
de nouvelles confréries notamment la
black axe qui voit le jour dans les
années 70
cette confrérie puis son idéologie dans
le mouvement afro-américain des Black
Panther il y avait vraiment l'éveil
d'une conscience noire sur le continent
à ce moment-là et blackags typiquement
veut avoir cette part là du récit et
donc chaque confraternité va se créer
comme ça avec une espèce d'idéologie un
peu propre à chacune au moins sur le
papier au départ et ils vont essayer mes
petit à petit ils sont encore
extrêmement craints parce que ils font
la pluie et le beau temps par exemple
sur le campus de benincity encore
aujourd'hui il y a des meurtres sur les
campus et juste en dehors des campus en
2020 lors des couvre-feu instaurés
pendant la crise sanitaire plusieurs
gangs ont mené des attaques contre la
population dans la région de Lagos la
capitale du Nigéria
parmi eux les One Million Boys qui
laissaient derrière eux se tracte
destiné aux habitants nous les invaincus
one million boys allons vous rendre
visite très prochainement alors
préparez-vous si vous ne vous soumettez
pas nous vous couperons les mains
nous sommes en 2019 à Palerme la
capitale de la Sicile la police
italienne a placé sur écoute les membres
d'un cut qui procède à un rite
d'initiation
la dimension mystique est quelque chose
de vraiment présent chez les cultes
depuis l'origine jusqu'à aujourd'hui le
rythme initiatique en est le premier
exemple il y a un passage à tabac
extrêmement violent pour éprouver la
résistance
né sur les campus du Sud du Nigéria dans
la seconde moitié du 20e siècle ont
chacun développé une identité propre
avec des rites un blason et une couleur
il y avait même quelque chose d'un petit
peu conquérant et qui consistait
vraiment à s'afficher avec les bérets
chacun sa couleur pour revendiquer son
appartenance et se mesurer les uns aux
autres puisque c'est extrêmement
conflictuel entre tous ces cultes mais
avec le temps on voit bien que ils ont
évolué et qu'ils ont compris que
s'afficher ne leur rendez pas service
dès lors que les polices européennes et
occidentales et autres se mettent à les
traquer c'est des politiciens ne conclus
cette variateur
nigériana Viking ou encore boucanier les
cultes s'affichent publiquement au
Nigeria sous couvert une association
caritative ils ont également des liens
avec le monde politique
tu prends l'exemple d'un ministre en
fait de l'état des dos donc où se trouve
Bénin City qui a été arrêté à Amsterdam
en transit et qui était considéré comme
le numéro 2 de mafaite au niveau mondial
c'est quelqu'un qui donc à écopé quand
même d'une peine de prison pour
association criminelle en Italie
contrairement au mafia traditionnel les
cultes fonctionnent de manière moins
organisée avec une structure plus
décentralisée ces gens-là disposent d'un
degré d'autonomie dans la commission
notamment des délits et des crimes qui
est très important ces organisations
prospère dans le trafic d'êtres humains
et contrôle en partie les camps de
migrants en Libye
ce sont eux qui gèrent les camps
nigérian et qui a servi et qui torture
et qui maltraite bien souvent leur
propre compatriotes
sont en forme de lacs
en Italie les cultes sont implantés
notamment à Palerme où ils se sont
faites une place dans le trafic de
drogue aux côtés de Cosa Nostra la mafia
sicilienne ce sont des repentis
siciliens eux-mêmes qu'ils le racontent
c'est qu'en fait ils sont montés en
grade ils ne se contentent plus en fait
de vendre au détail dans les rues de
Palerme parfois ce sont eux qui
fournissent la drogue parce qu'ils ont
quand même des réseaux avec le rôle que
je voulais l'Afrique de l'Ouest comme
plaque tournante en termes de transit de
la cocaïne mais le marché criminel sur
lequel les cuts s'enrichissent le plus
c'est le proxénétisme
ils envoient des femmes nigériennes vers
l'Europe et les soumets grâce à des
rites vaudou appelé juju me proposer de
vendre des vêtements en Italie avant de
partir j'ai dû aller quelque part avec
cette femme elle m'a fait boire une
potion
et fait juré que j'allais la payer
combien t'a-t-elle demandé de payer
25000 euros
que ce soit cause un austra en Sicile la
caméra à Naples ou même avec la
criminalité organisée à Marseille on
voit bien qu'en fait à chaque fois ils
ne peuvent occuper que le vide qu'on
veut bien leur laisser ils sont très
très loin de pouvoir s'imposer face à
des réseaux aussi structurés aussi
organisés et aussi bien armés